we don't care what happens
to anyone even if it's me
so we never learn the safety
rules because we're only
hey wait a minute who are these people
oh careless gnome skulls we are the safety patrol
we have come to drive you away from this fair line
but we want to stay here there is no place for
you careless gnome skulls on safety islands
be gone be gone
come children we will lead you to safety island
what an actor our tommy oh they were all
good well i have to scoot back to the office
all right dear i'll ride with
mrs keith we want to shop anyway
it was a lovely performance children this morning
you were all wonderful it was a fine safety play
thank you miss mitchell i'm not ever going
to be a callous numbskull i'm going to go out
to be a patrol boy like tommy
tucker and never be an accident
not him yes it is the boys told me when i called
the station just now the answers to the mayor
what in the hospital i'll be right over i tell
you mrs blake i was sick when i heard about it
just sick oh it's awful he was such
a oh i just can't talk about it
where's our tummy tummy tucker yes right through
there in the emergency room to the left thank you
yes yes they just brought him in i know
everybody in town is saying the same thing
why did it have to happen to him of all people
i know but but we're his parents i'm sorry
ready doctor we'll have to work fast
you'll have to stop and be identified son why
i know where i am this is the entrance to
safety island that's right lad i know it
why this is exactly like i thought it would be
just exactly i learned all about safety island and
our school patent of course your school pageant
was just play acting this is the real thing the
real safety island gee i think i'd like it here
that's fine son i'll get the book and check you in
now what's your name lad tommy tommy
tucker just like in the nursery rhyme
only i don't sing very well sir tucker tucker
oh tommy tucker is it why tommy i know all
about you you do sure i've been watching you
through my earthoscope look i'll show you
now tommy look right through there you
see that's a town where you live gee
but tommy uh now that i think of it you aren't
supposed to leave the earth for a long long time
as a matter of fact your
name isn't even in my book
it isn't no but look i've got an idea
we could use a fellow like you on safety
island maybe i can get permission to put your
name in the book i'd like that fine come with me
oh that's just some careless
gnome skulls over there
you mean they really are
careless gnome skulls oh yes
but you don't have to worry about them anymore
they can't get on the safety island come on
pulse is weak doctor very weak
well sir this is what happened there was an
accident the result of a little well carelessness
oh i see the gnome skulls again will
people never learn to look out for them
so all you have to do is a usual thing just give
me a written permit to put tommy's name in the
book here i'd like to recommend and in fact
i'd like to urge sir that you do it right now
then tommy is not yet i mean no sir not yet but if
you let me record his name that'll take care of it
automatically i see you see i well well i have a
very special reason for wanting to take advantage
of this particular case before i actually do
give you permission to write in tommy's name
suppose you tell me your very special
reason why you want tommy to uh
to join us here on safety island at this
time rather than later well it's a long
story sir here if you watch the screen on the
earthoscope here i'll turn the time dial back
well sir the story begins a little over a year
ago in tommy's hometown it was boys day you
know when the lads take over the city offices
well tommy here was acting mayor for the day
well tommy what would you do if you were really
mayor i mean for more than just today mr mayor
i try to make our town the
safest one in the country
and how would you do that just like i wrote my
essay in school i have a whole plan for doing
it and he did have a plan for a safety campaign
what's more it was a good one a practical plan
my dad helped me with it but the mayor liked
it he liked it so much made an official
proclamation that he did and the whole
town got behind it and put it over
it became the basis for a complete safety
program look as a result in less than six
months as far as traffic accidents were concerned
the town was actually the safest in the country
everybody cooperated and really got into the
spirit courtesy became the watchword of the
town
the police department established special safety
inspection lanes to be doubly sure that every
car in town met the safety standards the police
department also helped out by working with the
schools and teaching classes and pedestrian safety
to children now let's see how many can tell me
what's wrong with picture number two uh all right
young lady suppose you tell us what's wrong with
this picture he should have walked to the corner
where the patrol boy was that's absolutely right
now what else did he do that was wrong all right
should not have walked between the park cars
that's right and do all your children know why
because it is dangerous one of the cars
might start up and pinch his legs bad
another car might be coming along the
street and couldn't see him in time to stop
i know another reason you do and what's that
if you walk between the parked cars
he might get his new clothes dirty
that would make his mother mad
and her grown-ups too had lessons in safety the
parent teachers the civic club and well just about
every other organization in town did everything
possible to make the program a complete success
so as you can see the citizens committee has come
a long way in rounding out this the tommy tucker
safety program we've installed new signal lights
where needed and we've done a lot of other things
like getting rid of the blind
spot at the second avenue bridge
but this is merely a progress
report the job is far from finished
we still have a lot of well educating to do
because safety is always everybody's business
and believe me tommy really started something
with his safety program and it got results why
it wasn't long before every citizen of tommy's
town was safety minded all of the local automobile
dealers cooperated by reminding motorists to
maintain a regular mechanical check of their cars
one of them had a series of regularly scheduled
safety movies right in the showroom and not only
are our highways patrol painted with safety
lanes guarded with safety warning signs
and new signal lights installed where needed but
the highways themselves are engineered for safety
organizations such as the automobile manufacturers
association the inter-industry highway safety
committee the national safety council are
constantly working to improve the safety habits
of drivers and pedestrians alike and each year the
automobile manufacturers spend millions of dollars
designing and building still greater safety
into every possible part of the cars they make
yes the all steel bodies the safety glass sealed
beam headlights four-wheel hydraulic brakes
ever safer tires safety rims and the hundreds
of other safety features and refinements
contribute enormously to the
safe driving record of the car
but the complete the absolute safety of the car
depends on the skill the knowledge the safety
habits of the drivers and the pedestrians
in other words it all depends on you
so you can see sir that everybody in town
worked hard to put the safety program over
and our town really became the safest community in
the country too sir i even had my picture in a map
because our accident record was cut way way down
that's true well at least it was true for a while
and then gradually the old constant menace
came back again what's the constant men
what you said well tommy the constant
menace to safety is well it's carelessness
occasionally taking little chances you mean the
careless gnomes girls exactly let me explain
while we all know that a great number of accidents
are caused by plain reckless driving and by people
who break laws like jaywalking crossing against
the traffic signals driving too fast or driving
when intoxicated there are still a lot an awful
lot of accidents that are caused by people who
think they're good drivers or careful pedestrians
i call them the fringe people because they're
always on the fringe of an accident you know why
because every so often they take little chances
they become careless gnome skulls who think that
accidents can only happen to the other fellow
and i'll tell you something else almost
every person who drives is occasionally
guilty of this well this thoughtlessness
look i think you should see this sir
there's mr jb anderson now he knows better
than to get out on that side of the car
and as a rule he doesn't do it but today he takes
a chance he just doesn't think or look over here
see he forgot to signal well he got away
with it that time but someday he won't
there's a gnome skull racing to beat the light
just to save a few seconds and why didn't this
fellow wait until he was sure it was safe to
walk and how about this mrs foster wouldn't
think of breaking a traffic rule but she's
daydreaming at the wheel boy that was a close one
and look at this gnome skull
oh he knows better than that
that's mr stapleton he's even on the safety
committee now do you see what i mean by the
constant menace the fringe people who
every once in a while take chances yes
yes of course it was a driver just like that a
person who'd never had a serious accident before
who was the cause of the accident involving
tommy here of course that driver is very
sorry now he'd give anything in the world to
undo the harm but as always it's too late now
of course maybe it was kind of my fault too a
little bit maybe i was the careless gnomescar oh
but i wouldn't be if i could stay here on
safety island well sir i feel it might do
some real good if tommy stays up here with us how
well since tommy was so closely associated with
safety in his town his accident might
serve as an impressive object lesson
nurse is how's tommy the doctor says well if we
could only get tommy to help to fight to want to
oh tommy tommy please tell me please tell
me tommy tommy tommy i want you tommy
you know i i don't think i want to be an object
blessed after all i i think i want to go home
but son the very fact that you tommy tucker
the boy who inspired the safety campaign is
no longer there might have an effect on the town's
people like nothing else ever could exactly might
have the effect of shocking the people back into
their careful habits why it's working already look
charlie hooker has decided not to take a chance on
passing that truck yesterday he may have tried it
even billy phipps is making a proper arm
signal and he's remembering the rights of
pedestrians too and the pedestrians are waiting
at the curb waiting until the signal changes
don't you see tommy they're remembering you
and driving and walking safely see once again
they're remembering not to take those little
chances remembering not to be known skulls but
please sir my mommy and my dad are all worried
about me and and i don't want to stay here
won't you please please let me go back to my
mother and dad but tommy if you go back most of
the people will forget about this in a few weeks
and get careless all over again no they won't
please of course your parents won't forget
nor will the person who caused the accident
ever other people will remember too i i promise
i might honor as a cub scout to tell people not
to take chances when they drive or to be
careless about little things when they walk
most everybody wants to be good i just
know they do if you let me go back
i promise to tell everybody i see that they
just gotta be careful and keep their minds on it
all the time i'll tell the kids to be careful
when they walk or play i'll tell the grown-ups
to be careful when they drive and signal and
not speed or take even the tiniest chance ever
honest i will besides i don't want my accident
to ruin the life of the person who hit me
it wasn't on purpose i just know it
wasn't won't you please please let
me keep on living with my mother and dad i i
love them and they love me i want to go home
well sir i'm afraid it's no use you see i believe
as tommy grows up he will keep his promise
tommy i know that you and other boys and girls
like you are going to try to inspire others to
be safety-minded to develop safety habits
both as drivers and as pedestrians yes sir
we will so tommy is going to go
back tommy is going to be all right